how many members or insiders of Congress
are on the same page we like yeah this
sucks cuz I I got to say like there
have to be
some you know that's you are absolutely
right that's that was one of the things
that really fueled me to take the leap
from a tene job for life at the
Congressional research service to a
non-tenure position in a think tank it
was everybody on Capital Hill with the
exception of a
few outrageous characters is miserable
they're not having fun they came here to
do stuff and they're finding themselves
just swallowed up in Byzantine goofiness
that's not satisfying and I kept
wondering like look you
people per the Constitution have all the
power to change why don't you and it
seemed to be a kind of collective action
problem a learned helplessness where
people just kind of looked around and
Shrugged like yeah that's the way this
place is and I started trying to say
like look it hasn't always been like
this and it doesn't have to be this way
you can reorganize you can fund yourself
as much as you want just be the change
Congress is not set up as an institution
to succeed and I'm I'm going to throw a
few things out there that I that I when
I found out I was like whoa that's
messed up um so there there's been a
rule in place for a number of years now
I think it's uh called a h rule where
you can't bring legislation to the floor
unless it's supported by a majority of
the majority which means that if you're
in the minority party you're doing very
very little
legislating because you can't actually
bring anything so someone in Congress
said to me that if you're in the
minority party you might as well be a
piece of furniture um now of course most
members of Congress aren't going to be
like yeah I just kind of hang out and
you know don't do anything um but if
you're in the minority party that
unfortunately is is what it resembles
sure yeah ABS absolutely uh the sort of
collegiality
um
between partisans to you know work with
one another uh particularly on high
salience issue it's just it's almost
non-existent um take any big issue like
immigration you you just are not going
to see Democrats and Republicans talking
with each other uh and working together
on Solutions um they just don't feel
incentivized to do that I mean the good
news is is that on like really boring
low aliens issues they've got the space
to do it um but funny enough your
question leads us to the primary
issue think about it immigration if
you're the Democratic party do you
really want to solve that problem if
you're the Republican Party do you
really want to solve that problem no
you've got pretty strong incentives to
not solve it but rather to campaign upon
it to fundraise upon it and therefore
you own the issue but you don't own the
solution and that's particularly the
case when you're running through the
primaries where you have people who are
either really hard on the left or really
hard on the right who are more than
likely to vote in those primaries and so
yeah that's part that's part of the
problem the Hast rule kind of is a
reflection of the incentive structure um
that's currently in place so what are
the major things that you've been
pushing for on the outside world uh in
your book and otherwise you're like look
guys I came from the Batts of Congress I
was a nonpartisan nerd I know how stuff
works there and doesn't work and here's
what we should do yeah well certainly I
would start with uh Staffing Staffing up
on the nonpartisan nerds having those as
a resource and as a counterbalance
against the kind of private sector
moneyed interest pressures uh that get
in congress's
ears um that's that's the first thing
you have you have to do uh the second
thing you have to do is to
start drawing on some of the insights
gained by the select committee and the
modernization of Congress about how to
run committees in ways that are just
less toxic for all
involved um you know one of the things
that the Select Committee of the
modernization Congress figured out that
you put people at a round table and you
seat them kind of Dem Republican Dem
Republican instead of splitting it up
into two sides and you have the
witnesses interspersed there you can
have real
conversations and sometimes if you want
to be really clever you you don't have
to call it a hearing you can have it be
a round table which means you don't have
to have the cameras there so the
incentive to act up in front of the
cameras and use that as a vehicle for
fundraising or partisan Point scoring
those incentives go away and you can
have Frank conversations where people
are able to say like I don't know you're
a Republican and you got something
interesting to say to me as a Democrat
on this issue I think we might have
grounds to get together on that when a
camera is pres you can't do that so that
would be certainly one way and but
process our nation's finances are a
wreck that law has to be Rewritten Soup
To Nuts to fix the
situation hey YouTube thanks for
watching please do hit like And
subscribe and hit that Bell if you want
to be notified every time a new episode
drops thank
you